[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the spectacle of illegal
immigrants separated from their children
the border has ceased to be a news story
in any traditional sense of the term it
is now an event a kind of competition in
which elites vie to see who can reach
greater heights of rhetorical excess in
self-righteous posturing it is
performance art really
congresswoman Nancy Pelosi and even
Hillary Clinton took an early lead in
the contest by bypassing publicity
public policy questions entirely and
moving straight to theology here part of
their sermons watch the hypocrisy of all
people of faith in our country not to
clamour for this for what the
administration is doing to end those who
selectively use the Bible to justify
this cruelty are ignoring a central
tenet of Christianity jesus said suffer
the little children unto me he did not
say let the children suffer so the same
people who support third term post
viability abortion for purposes of sex
selection are now lecturing you about
God and sin and the holiness of children
feel chastened but wait there's more so
much more on Facebook senator Ben Sasse
called the administration's policy
wicked as in immoral and devilish former
first lady Laura Bush likened it to the
internment of the Japanese during World
War two a moral stain upon this nation
former CIA director Michael Hayden went
all the way he tweeted out a picture of
Auschwitz death camp and compared the US
government to the Nazis after sobering
up Hayden walked that back a little bit
on television but not much watch I know
we're not Nazi Germany alright but there
is a commonality there I've lived in
Germany for three years a more civilized
people you cannot find but general and
so I was trying to point out we need be
careful not to move in that direction oh
we could go on there is so much more
just like that the rich and powerful
reminding you just how virtuous they are
you thinking these people really care
about family separation if they did
they'd be worried about the collapse of
the American family which is measurable
and real but they're not worried about
that
in fact they welcome that collapse
because strong families are an
impediment to their political power
that's why they're always lecturing you
about the patriarchy and the evil of the
nuclear family millions and millions of
American kids are growing up with one
parent at home family separated
thanks to their policies and that's fine
with them many of those kids by the way
have a parent behind bars it's not just
illegal immigrants who are separated
from their children the majority of
American citizens in prison have minor
kids they've left behind their families
have been separated by force by our
justice system because they committed a
crime so in that way these kids are just
like the kids you've been watching on
television today the difference of
course is they're Americans so nobody is
spending thirty five grand a year apiece
to make sure they're okay Democratic
politicians and cable news anchors don't
visit their foster homes to highlight
their plight they're ignored this is one
of those moments that tells you
everything about our ruling class they
care far more about foreigners than
about their own people you probably
suspected that already the other thing
you may have noticed is that they're not
especially interested in solutions to
anything they're great at yelling and it
preening not so good at fixing and
building we could strengthen our borders
to keep illegals out we could fund more
immigration courts to process those who
sneak through anyway we can even build
more housing facilities at the border
holding facilities to allow families to
stay together while their asylum claims
are processed but the left is not
interested in any of that their only
solution is immediate amnesty for anyone
who crosses our borders with a minor in
tow and of course that's the same as no
borders at all not to mention a powerful
incentive for child smuggling they don't
care because no matter what they tell
you this is not about helping children a
lot of people are yelling at you on TV
don't even have children so don't for a
second let them take the moral high
ground their goal is to change your
country forever and they're succeeding
by the way since 2014 to name one
example among many at least half a
million Central Americans who came here
illegally have been released back inside
our borders did anyone vote for that and
what a point who's going to pay for that
not the people you've been watching on
television today their kids go to
private school if they have them their
neighborhoods look exactly like they did
in 1960 no demographic change at all
just like they like it there's no cost
to them the cost is entirely on you but
don't complain or else they will call
you Hitler